à moins qu'on ne t'a pas loin de 50 ans
ouais ben on va faire une petite une
période hachée quatre ans le top 1
alors la taille c'est toujours un mètre
quatre-vingt ça ça change pas beaucoup y
ont vu un peu hein
le poète est toujours à 85 ah non je
variable ouais c'était à combien
lorsqu'on doit je ne sais pas on n'a
rien pour se laver les dents ça va être
dans bones ont toujours pas méchant hein
tu te la cloche à l'origine alors j'en
ai deux qui m'ont fait très gros combler
quelques années que j'ai fait changer
et alors depuis et se marrant je marche
mieux à les yaourts yoplait
il n'y a pas eu de rejet et madonna les
cheveux ça va ça incroyable crayon un da
toutes tes cheveux ben est très belle
chevelure
quel est ton secret
quel est ton secret c'est incroyable
même chose pour les yeux comment ils
vont tes petits dieux et ils vont mal
parce qu'il écoute et moi ma chère
madame
j'aime beaucoup ce que j'aime beaucoup
vos chaussures il est élégant mais c'est
vrai que dans les yeux t'as combien tu
sais à peu près les démérol non je vous
pour recevoir face entre ceux entre le
chien et la casse mais ça va certes non
voyants et l'activité sexuelle un
ralentissement de piotta
comme dit woody allen la dernière fois
c'était dans la statue de la liberté
c'est une dame quand même ouais des les
opérations deux opérations ou de betty
juteux de la jambe
ouais enfin rien de spécial non c'était
darif
un fait alors ça va maintenant
d'epictète au pea je pense plus à mon
écoute maintenant le temps preuve le
champ
les entrées valaisan des angles sans
dérange pas les angles non non noir je
mange les peaux parce que on peut mettre
des produits dessus donc user croyons
que les ombres sur un petit peu durs et
c'était les maladies chroniques non non
pas là bas il incarne pourquoi j'ai dit
non mais bon ça va enfin de chez quatre
des énergies non à part aux éditeurs
telle étape à d'énergie ça non mais non
mais attention animateur télé d'abord
sais pas mais qui est un passe-temps toi
tu t'amuses mais je vais vous bien et
steve est allée des rues des rues non
mais alors parlons famille maintenant tu
es très cocooning finalement parce que
je lisais l'autre jour un article le
concernant qui avait été écrit au début
des années 60
ouais et alors exit est tous en train de
se déchirer et tout et toi tu étais avec
françoise à noisy-le-sec en territoire
vous n'êtes pas le fait que
gr ii des journaleux emmerdeur viennent
vous voir donc si on est tranquille
ils ont rien à raconter donc ça permet
de faire toutes les conneries du monde
sans qu'on vous emmerde
mais ce qui est important et les enfants
ils sont casés ça va à caser ces jeunes
anciens seulement il va et dit oui diva
trop viser un vrai dit il son vrai nom
doudou comment ça va bien il va très
très bien son bras mais là ça va tout ça
quand ça va être très longue liste
emmerdeuse le tabac mais à combien la
barre je suis à moins de papier un nom
c'est bien qu'on fait arrive en bonne
santé quand même un peu pourquoi mais je
sais pas parce que tu as pris un moment
d'autres substances un peu plus
illicites quand même non oui mon faux
trop fragile unité rioux tu disais une
petite l'insee bien avant d'aller chez
guy lux comprend non mais c'est vrai non
mais oh pardon j'ai jamais non plus dès
qu'il fait en compte bien l'allemand
personne dit 'tiens je perçois un
sourire et l'alcool à un moment c'était
quand même à une bouteille de chivas par
jour je me souviens - non non ce que
chivas
heureusement tes épaules permis à
l'époque dit non quand même plus loin tu
te rends compte
pourquoi bas parce qu'avec une bouteille
de chivas par jour l'alcootest ah mais
je n'ai pas le paquet sur nos murs ouais
puis rejoint ce n'est pas une femme non
plus tu vas boire répondra-t-il valoir